hi there everyone I'm on holiday at the
moment but like any numberphile I'm
thinking about numbers and I've been so
impressed with all the one role
yahtzee's you've been sending in I've
decided to up the ante so I've got some
dice here I'm going to go for another
one roll Yahtzee but have a look at this
I'll show you where I'm going to do it
I'm going to need this that's a bit of a
clue got my flippers and there is the
Indian Ocean that's where I'm going to
go from my underwater Maldivian one roll
Yahtzee
so while I head on out to see here are
the latest videos from you the viewers
firstly dude and chaos a fan of Rube
Goldberg machines came up with this
inspired contraption and then when a
step further we know there's a one in
1296 chance of rolling five matching
dice 1/6 matching dice one in 7776 but
it's no dice this time I'm afraid
I'm still struggling underwater here are
some people who were more successful yes
oh my god yeah so this is for number
fail YouTube channel lady okay
Yahtzee
Chansey
[Music]
yes
you see - Skeeter Yeti
[Music]
this isn't proving easy maybe some
homemade software's the key
[Music]
now I mentioned how tough a six-star CRT
is but here's someone who did it not
everyone so lucky here's someone who
never got a Yahtzee but still sent in
the video and you know what even
migrating to dry land now I don't seem
to be having much luck either stay tuned
to numberphile though because we do have
more videos coming including a very
special Yahtzee contribution from
someone you may recognize you Brady it's
very hard and as promised I'm going to
throw you a Yahtzee that's definitely
going to be one worth watching here's
the link to all our previous Yahtzee
videos but I promised the next
numberphile video that won't have any
dice at all because well frankly I'm
sick of the sight of them
[Music]